[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAVE GEFFON: Hi, everyone.
I'm Dave Geffon.
Welcome to the
Google Developer Day
here at the Games
Developer Conference.
Just a minute ago,
if you were here,
you saw Adam give a really great
talk with some great panelists
on the importance of launching
and the tools and tech
that Google Play gives to you
to actually launch successfully
on the platform.
If you're a new developer,
you're an existing developer,
you know that launch
is really critical.
And I think one of the
things that I always
hear from developers
from all walks of life
is, well, I've
nailed that launch.
I've got all these installs.
These people are playing
and loving my game.
And I just really don't
quite know what to do next.
And today I've actually
got a great panel here
of some really great
games industry leaders who
are doing some truly--
it's true.
Don't be so-- these guys.
They're doing some really
great, innovative things
in terms of building and growing
their communities in some kind
of nonconventional ways.
So before we get
started, I'm not sure
that everyone here
knows who you guys are.
So why don't we start
here with Christian.
Tell us a little bit about
yourself, your company,
and what you guys are doing.
KRISTIAN SEGERSTRALE: Sure.
So my name is
Kristian Segerstrale.
I'm the chief executive
of Super Evil Megacorp.
I nearly said cheese there
instead of too, that too.
But anyway, we are makers of
"Vainglory," the number one
mobile eSport today.
So as a company, what we're
really focused on doing
is creating, for the
touchscreen generation,
the kind of real
time, deep competitive
experiences that we grew
up with on PC ourselves.
And that style of
gaming lends itself
very much to working with
the community as opposed
to focusing very much
on an upfront launch.
So we spend 90% of our
efforts really trying
to figure out how to be a
better company everyday,
to how to make the
community happier everyday,
and can share some
learnings from that.
ANDREW STALBOW: Hey,
I'm Andrew Stalbow.
I'm a co-founder and
CEO at Seriously.
We believe that
the next generation
of entertainment brands
get built on mobile first.
And we're working
really hard to build out
our first property
called "Best Fiends"
into a big franchise that
feels like a Hollywood property
but starts its life
as a mobile app.
ANDRES BOU: Hi everyone.
I'm Andres Bou.
I'm CEO and founder
of Social Point.
We are a game developer
based in Barcelona,
so in the sunny Spain.
And we are mainly known
by "Dragon City," "Monster
Legends."
Both titles were
launched in mobile
more than three years ago.
And that's why we
are here today,
now to talk about how to make
that games can sustain there
for a long period of time.
DAVE GEFFON: Awesome.
So you guys are clearly
running and developing
games that are very
successful on Google Play.
What was that moment where
you're leading this business
and you realize, hey,
we need to do something
different to resonate
with our audience
and to grow our audience?
What was that moment
for you, Kristian?
KRISTIAN SEGERSTRALE:
Yeah, so for us
it was actually very much
right at the very beginning
because we went out with
a gaming proposition that
was fundamentally different to
anything that was out there.
Instead of aiming for
that proverbial bus stop
moment of two or three
minutes of fun, which
was very much the
market a few years ago,
we went out wanting to create a
gaming experience where people
could play all night
long with their friends,
just like we did
growing up on PC.
So by coming up with a
gaming experience that
is where the file size
is sort of 700 megabytes
plus in terms of the shared
commitment to the download,
as well as the fact that
when you start a game,
you're expected to play that
game for 20 to 25 minutes,
or in fact if you
get out early, we
will have to punish
you because you
ruin the experience
for everyone else
in that match, that to us was a
very clear fundamental starting
point that there's no way that
we can go ahead and try to run
a big campaign,
get lots of people
into this, because
it fundamentally
requires a different mindset.
It is almost like growing a
different type of culture.
This style of long
form gaming has had,
like if you think about
it, if you take a game like
"Counter-Strike," and first
person shooters in general,
they were around in
early 2000s, right?
They're still growing because
they created a gaming culture
around real time gaming.
And that hasn't yet
happened, or rather we're
very early days in mobile.
So for us it was
that realization
that you need to come into this
game with a different mindset.
So there's no way that we
can go out and market it
like a traditional game.
We need to do something
different in how we bring it
up.
ANDREW STALBOW: So we
started three years ago.
And we basically felt
like the opportunity
was to challenge
the way things were
being done, both on the product
side and marketing side.
And for us, I'd say
right the beginning
we knew we had to
do it differently,
otherwise there
was just no way we
were going to cut through
against very, very big
incumbents in the mobile space.
So for us, what we
saw as the opportunity
was try and find
ways to build a story
and introduce a
world and characters,
and really come up
with a beautiful brand
on the front end.
And whereas a lot
of game companies
tended to add that
layer on quite late,
we built the story
first and then designed
a game that would
really bring that out
in a really special way.
And then on the
marketing side, we
knew that we would
not be able to compete
with the big companies
on Facebook and Twitter
and performance
marketing acquisition,
which was ultimately
very expensive, and said,
well, hey, can we be super
creative about the way we
market and try and find ways
to bring installs in and bring
players in a much more
cost effective way than
through performance
marketing platforms,
and also at the same time,
differentiate ourselves
with a nice creative
marketing experience that
helps kind of build our brand.
Because ultimately our
mission is build a great brand
in the world.
So like Kristian,
right at the beginning.
ANDRES BOU: For us, we do
it on our gaming basis.
So every game we have to make
sure that in two years from now
we'll have all the
meaningful things.
We challenge ourselves
to think, OK,
how are going to be the
games in two years, in three
years from now, and make sure
that all the new games that we
have in development have
all those ingredients.
Because if not, they will
not be trending at that time.
And to be honest with
you, when we launched
"Dragon City" and
"Monster Legends,"
we didn't believe that
they could last so long.
Initially we thought maybe
two years, maybe three years.
Now we are approaching
the games that they can
sustain 10 years or even more.
So it's taking a lot of
effort in the community,
in the users, in
the relative users,
making sure that we listen
to them, that we launch
and we develop what
they are aiming for,
and making sure that everything
evolves on the right path.
DAVE GEFFON: Yeah,
I think the thing
I keep hearing is that
this is like a very
deliberate in the
way you're thinking
and the way you're approaching
your strategy for your games.
Clearly you're thinking
years are out, years ahead.
There's a lot of
new kind and kind
of emergent trends
in games right now.
So I mean obviously VR's big.
AR is just around the corner.
Is there anything
that you're seeing
that's making you either kind of
question your current strategy
or think about, is it
time to pivot or kind of
add to what we're doing?
KRISTIAN SEGERSTRALE:
Well one thing
that I think is really,
really clear that we've just
been delighted to see
throughout has been,
as a game that focuses on
the competitive experience
and focuses on the spectated
experience just as much
as the actual play experience,
and having millions of people
playing and watching every
month already, is the growth,
and the growth rate of people
watching other people play.
That's happening obviously
very quickly on PC,
but it's happening even
faster on mobile right now.
If you saw the presentation
from this morning,
spectation in mobile
games on YouTube
as well as on other
platforms is really
growing much faster
than PC gaming
right now, which
makes a lot of sense.
But that interaction between--
because it creates so many
more dynamics between you
and your community when
people enjoy watching people
play your game.
It enables you to
work much more closely
with a video format as
a way of communicating
with your users
and your players.
It enables you to,
frankly, bring some
of that back into the
game, the video created
by your competitors.
And of course it
enables you to set up
live events where people
compete with each other
and a lot of people will
come and watch them.
That dynamic and the speed at
which it is growing right now
is amazing.
It took PC gaming
probably, what,
10 years to go from the very
first streamed, spectated
experiences to where
we are at right now
with literally
hundreds of millions
watching in any given month.
Mobile is catching up
very, very rapidly.
That to me is a really
encouraging trend.
It really makes us double down
even further on ensuring things
like that you can stream
directly from device,
you can record video
and there are
meaningful ways and
meaningful online
communities for the game
to share what you have created.
Because that level of
community interaction
is really unique and
growing very rapidly.
ANDREW STALBOW: I think what's
super exciting about mobile is
we're all creating
portraits that are actually
live services.
And I'm sure like
us, most of you
are updating your apps
every three or four weeks
and you're adding new features.
And I think what that gives
us all an amazing opportunity
to do is for the first time,
really small developers--
I mean, we're a tiny
team of 50 people.
But we're connected to 2 million
people playing every day,
spending around an hour
a day in our products.
And we get to learn from
that data, iterate on it.
And every time there's
a new opportunity,
whether it be integrating
video into your app
or whether it be
integrating replay
or whether it be kind of
designing and updating
new features because
you've seen something that
seems like a great
opportunity for your product,
the amazing thing
about the platform
is we all get to be able to
kind of update very quickly
and iterate on
changes that we see.
So I definitely think that's
one of the most amazing things
about mobile is we do get the
chance to react and iterate
on that.
ANDRES BOU: For me, I'm not
a big fan or believer of VR,
not yet.
I totally agree with Kristian.
eSports, it's going to be
super huge and super big.
I think the future is
also about competition,
peer to peer real time.
And social and
building communities,
it's also a key element.
DAVE GEFFON: So eSports,
competitive gaming
seems to be like a kind of
forefront of your thinking.
What is it about eSports other
than the obvious that it's
great to watch people
play games when
you're passionate about them.
What do you think just
keeps these people coming
back for more and more?
KRISTIAN SEGERSTRALE:
Well you were formerly
a competitive player so you
may know more about this than--
DAVE GEFFON: I love games
and have no self-control.
That's why.
KRISTIAN SEGERSTRALE:
That's great.
Well I guess the way
we think about it is,
I think there's so much
hype and talk about eSports
right now that sometimes is
kind of worth just sort of maybe
bringing it back
to kind of putting
your feet on the ground.
At the end of the day, we
are excited about building
that experience that
made us when we grew up
spend nights on end
at friends' houses
with our PC playing together as
a team against some strangers
over some kind of dial
up connection somewhere.
And I think it is that
fundamental thing of creating
an experience that people
want to play as a team,
if it is fun enough, people
end up rewarding you,
if you're a
developer, by wanting
to play a competitive game.
That's what really
blew our mind last year
was we thought we had so much
work to do and product still.
I mean at the end of the
day, a real time multiplayer
game on mobile which pushes
1.3 million polygons on screen
at any one time at 60
FPS is like, we just
felt like there
was a lot of work
here to do before
we get to a point
where we would even
begin to think about
how would we encourage a
competitive scene for the game.
But the community ran away
with it, to be honest.
Really early on their
first ask was, hey,
can we have a spectator mode?
When is the first
tournament going to be?
People started organizing
tournaments inside
of the community.
I think last year we had
over 6,000 registered
teams kind of various
community tournaments
with some prize pools and
things and then all the way
leading up to the
world championships
with more than 25,000 people
watching at the same time
back in December,
which is pretty cool.
But I think ultimately,
we think that the success
of the competitive community
is a product of listening
to the community throughout.
We try to think of ourselves
first and foremost as players,
ourselves, but then also
inviting the player base
in to come and be co-creators
of the experience.
We just released
yesterday as part
of an invitational
tournament where
we're celebrating some of
the big new teams coming
into "Vainglory," like
Miami Heat acquired
a "Vainglory" team, as
well as some others.
And we released a video
about our 2017 plans,
about what we are
thinking of making
and what we're thinking
of creating and asking
for community feedback.
And it's amazing how just
that level of transparency
with communication
with the community
really lights up what
the community's passions.
And they frankly help us.
They are sort of
a North Star of,
are we taking this game
in the right direction?
So competitive play is
simply the community
at its very highest
level showing you,
in some ways as
the developer, what
the game can be if you take
it in the correct direction.
So we're always amazed
at how many people play
and how many people are part
of the competitive scene.
And frankly now I think
there's approaching
50 people in the world who
play "Vainglory" as a living,
like that is their
main job right now.
And that obviously,
as a developer,
gives you even more reason
to do a good job to make sure
that the scene keeps on
growing and that you're
a better game every day.
ANDREW STALBOW: I think
that's the real key.
We all get to react to
the data, in our games,
but we also get to react to
the community, whether it
be comments in the
stores or whether it
be in your social
communities as well.
And what we're seeing
across the board is,
obviously, everyone's playing
because they're competitive.
And now you've got the
tools and the ability
to kind of get even
more competitive.
And I think what you're
going to start seeing on,
like the definition of eSports
right now feels a little bit
more kind of midcore or core.
But I think it's going to
feel very, very-- well,
it's going to feel very, very
casual over the next couple
of years as more and
more products come out
and as the audience gets
more and more used to it.
ANDRES BOU: We don't have
pure eSports games, not yet.
But we have a lot of social
and competition in our games.
And I think human being, it's
quite competitive by itself.
And so at the end, making sure
that games are also competitive
and bringing those experience
into the digital world,
it makes total sense.
And we have launched
many, many, many features
in "Monster Legends" about
social, about competition.
And we saw-- we know
from saying today
that we launched that
feature, engagement going up,
people going back
and fighting more,
and even also paying more.
So it's, people
love that experience
and they are aiming for more.
DAVE GEFFON: So
one thing I think
that I've kind of
heard all of you
touch on, which is the
community aspect of sharing
and watching and being
passionate about a game,
your particular games.
How are you using your biggest
fans, influencers, the people
who are the biggest
advocates for your game
to either extend your
message, extend your brand,
and just kind of help grow
your community organically?
KRISTIAN SEGERSTRALE:
Well we certainly
try to work with the community
as much as humanly possible.
I don't know that we use
the commutative per se.
I think sometimes I
feel like they use us,
in terms of just the
sheer amount of hours
that we put into trying to
do things that they want.
But the way that
we think about it
is, firstly, we, of course,
have a vision of what
we want to build over
the next five to 10
to 15 years, which
is all about bringing
that competitive experience that
we've seen really blossom on PC
and console, that
real time experience,
but that hasn't really yet
come to mobile, that culture
of playing together real time.
We believe that that
community, whoever
does as good a job with
that on mobile as a Blizzard
or a Riot or a
Valve has done on PC
will ultimately be an
incredibly successful game
over the next five to 10 years.
And that's what we are
committed to building everyday.
And we feel like
the best way to get
there is to try and
find as many people
like us who love this style
of gaming on these devices
and work with them.
So it starts all
the way from a--
we have a private
closed beta group.
We release the next release
three or four weeks earlier
for, in the order of hundreds of
players, in order to help test
and think about the very detail
of what's about to come next.
We have a much,
much larger group
of folks who hang
out on our forums
and who we frequently invite
in and just ask about, hey,
what do they think
about this direction?
And then there's the
entire player base
where we take some of them,
we solicit opinion a lot.
We ask questions.
We do everything from
surveys all the way
to literally just
run competitions
for ideas and whatnot.
But then on top of that
if the community goes
through the effort of
creating something,
like creating a video
or creating a poem
or like a great piece of
fan art or whatever it is,
we really try to go out of our
way to feature that in game,
wherever possible, to sort of
give back to the community,
show back to the community
our appreciation.
Because ultimately that
helps these content creators
get discovered, by a
player base of millions.
And if they do a good
job and repeatedly put
out good videos and
good things, they
end up growing
their follower base.
So we just try to work
together in all different ways.
And again, we obviously want to
push the game in the direction
that we believe is
right in the long term.
But a lot of the
time the community
is there way before us in
terms of spotting problems
with potential
directions of the game,
as well as just being
very loud with feedback,
which is amazing.
ANDREW STALBOW: Well we have
a slightly different approach
to community to Kristian's.
So we've got about 7 million
people connected to us
across the social media
channels, email newsletters.
And we've now got to a point
where we're providing content
to them two or three
times a day through each
of those connections.
The thing that I think
is ultimately interesting
is, you need to
address community
right from the beginning.
If you think the
first point of contact
when you start marketing to
people about your product
and your game and the world
that you're offering--
a good example of
that for us is we
work really closely with
a lot of different YouTube
influencers.
And we found that the most
amazing way to bring people
into our experience
is find ways for them
to not just market the game but
kind of come inside our product
too.
And we've run
competitions where people
can choose to join different
influencers' teams.
And it gets people
in the mindset
that this content
is really a kind
of engaging two way experience.
And it's something
kind of really,
really fun for people to be able
to try and compete or support
their biggest stars.
So I'd say to you,
thing when you're
thinking about
building community
is also integrate all community
thinking in your marketing
strategies too.
ANDRES BOU: We try to
consider communities
as part of the team.
I mean it's very
hard to do that,
but we try to work with them.
So we have weekly
calls with them.
We have even early access of
some features just for them,
to listen the feedback.
Sometimes we don't agree
with what they say,
but we will listen to them and
we decide what's reasonable
and what we should change
or include in our games.
And for building
communities, I totally agree.
Using influencers or YouTubers,
it's a huge weapon to do that.
My only advice to
that, it's you have
to make sure that the
influencers' audience matches
perfectly with
your game audience.
Because we have run many,
many campaigns with YouTubers,
many of them very successful,
some of them also big failures.
And the number one
lesson that they learn
is make sure that the
audience has a perfect fit.
DAVE GEFFON: So
one last question
before we open it
up to Q&A. Obviously
there's developers in this
room from all walks of life,
small one, two man studios
to maybe 30 people plus.
What's one thing everyone in
this room, regardless of size,
can do today to better
serve their community?
KRISTIAN SEGERSTRALE: I
think everyone was once
a one or two person studio.
Just that's the way game
companies grow, right?
And I think community
is a mindset.
There's nothing you
can do today that will
double the size
of your community
or triple it or
suddenly set you up
to be super successful
in the future.
It's just a mindset,
and you just
have to trust that it will come.
If you treat your
players the way
that you would want to
be treated as a player,
if you invite them along, you're
honest, transparent, patient,
and you build the game in a
way that you would want to be--
and you communicate
out in the way
that you would want to be
communicated to as a player,
good things come.
It just simply takes time.
We live in this
world where people--
certainly over the past
few years there's been,
we've built this
expectation that you've
got to be successful overnight.
And if you're not in the top
10 grossing in your first two
weeks, you should kill the
game and move on and rapid,
fail fast, and all that stuff.
Not so with community.
You can't fail fast
with community.
You've got to simply grow
it and be brave enough
to truly be transparent
and if you like,
be naked in front
of your community,
for the good and bad.
When you make a
mistake, admit it.
When you do something well,
listen to the community
and see if you can help
celebrate it together
with them.
So to treat them as
part of the team,
I actually quite liked
that comment earlier.
ANDREW STALBOW: Yeah, I
double down on that one.
I'd say show that you care.
And ultimately if
you're creating
an authentic experience that is
something you care passionately
about that isn't
about money first
but it's actually about
kind of engagement
and a really
beautiful experience
that everybody
can enjoy, I think
that sets you up brilliantly.
And it's amazing
how suddenly you
get all these communities
built around what you're
doing because they've seen the
effect you've made on your art
or on your design or on
the music that, you know,
80% of people put on mute but
you've made the effort on.
And I think that the
minute you show you care,
it's unbelievable what happens.
ANDRES BOU: I wouldn't focus
on growing the community.
So I think everyone should
focus on improving the game
and improving the product.
Get the community
and listen to them
to try to make your
product better.
That's what I would
focus on 100%.
ANDREW STALBOW: You know,
I'll just add to that.
We have a little saying
inside the company which
is like do the right thing.
So any time you're
in any doubt, invest
into these things
over the long term
and do the right
thing because that's
going to come back
and help your brand.
It's like Andre
said, these people
are now building apps that
I think a couple of years
ago maybe you thought
they might have
a life cycle of 12, 18 months.
But now I think most
of us are thinking
they could be significantly
longer than that.
It's a really good opportunity.
DAVE GEFFON: Excellent.
So we're going to open
it up to questions.
There's two mics on either side.
So feel free to
come up if you want
to ask any of these fantastic
members of our panel
a specific question.
KRISTIAN SEGERSTRALE: Or this
fantastic moderator right here.
DAVE GEFFON: Thank you.
I'll just start over here.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm a game developer.
I have two questions.
First question is
for all of you.
What kind of genre
do you think it's
worth to build communities,
because we're really small.
We only have 10 people.
We are working on a
single player game.
It's a tower defense game.
It's already out,
but we're not quite
sure how much effort
we should invest
in building the community.
Second question is for Kristian.
It's my personal question.
What's your answer
to "Mobile Legends"?
DAVE GEFFON: What's your
answer to "Mobile Legends"?
KRISTIAN SEGERSTRALE: OK.
I'll take the first
question first.
ANDRES BOU: So on
the first question,
I would focus on everything
that is competitive.
So I would go for RPGs,
strategy kind of games.
I think that the kind of
gameplays and mechanics
that those games have makes the
creation of communities quite
easier compared to other ones
that are more single player
modes or this kind of.
ANDREW STALBOW:
I think if you've
got a product that
other people love,
it's worth spending the time on.
I think that the best
marketing you can ever do
is word of mouth.
And if you build a
platform that people
are excited to talk about,
you should give them
the tools and the ability
to invest into that.
So I'd say community
building is probably the best
marketing you'll ever do.
KRISTIAN SEGERSTRALE:
Yeah, overall, today, and I
think somebody said
in the previous panel,
just acquiring users just
purely through thinking
of running video ads
on Facebook or Twitter
or something like that is
just incredibly expensive.
So I'd be surprised
if a distribution
strategy, especially for an
early stage startup today,
would not have community as
a pretty large part of it
one way or the other.
As far as your
second question, you
were asking what's
my answer, what's
our answer to "Mobile Legends."
I think, look, we don't have a
patent on real time multiplayer
gaming, right?
I mean, this is a
phenomenon that's
grown on PC over
the past 20 years.
And we're frankly just excited
that there are more and more
products that help drive the
culture of online real time
play on the mobile platform.
And there will be
many products that are
going to come out this year.
There were some
already last year.
We were super happy
when "Clash Royale"
came out as a
first 1v1 real time
experience, and more
team-based experiences
coming out this year in the form
of shooters, mobiles, RTSes.
All of that stuff is
like where PC gaming
was literally 20 years ago.
And that to us is exciting.
And frankly we can learn
a lot from other products
that are out there.
And the thing I will say is that
there is no company out there
that is as committed
to this experience,
both in terms of technology,
in terms of design,
in terms of approach
to community,
and approach to competitive
play today than we are.
And we're just excited to be
part of that broader community
and part of that broader change,
if you like, in the industry
toward far more real time play.
AUDIENCE: Thank you very much.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
We've found that building
community within the game,
having players be able to
interact with each other
and form emotional relationships
who meet in the game, who don't
know each other previously, is
an incredibly strong motivator
of retention.
But we've noticed that
mobile games don't
tend to have very serious
ways to interact emotionally
with other players you don't
have preexisting relationships.
Is that a direction you
are looking to move into?
And do you have
any insight on why
it's so difficult on mobile?
KRISTIAN SEGERSTRALE:
From our perspective,
I completely agree with you.
If you look at the
retention patterns of people
who are friends or who
are part of, in our case,
guilds or teams
inside of the game
and who communicate
with each other a lot,
it's very different from the
retention pattern of somebody
who plays purely on their own.
So that is clearly right.
I think a lot of
when you deal with,
especially smaller
screen real estate,
it's sometimes just design-wise
harder to think about,
how do you put a
chat box everywhere
when the screen is kind of small
and when the keyboard obscures
half of the action?
How do you, in that context, do
that in the best possible way?
So we think a lot
about different ways
of improving
communication in the game
and enabling the formation
of those relationships.
We have, certainly as a
company and as a game,
we have a lot to learn from many
other products in that area.
But I think what you're
saying is exactly right.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hello, and this
question is about "Vainglory,"
so I guess it's for Kristian.
Before "Vainglory"
was a success,
before it was known
for its quality and all
that stuff, the first contact
with the community, how was it?
How did you communicate
to the community?
Where do you start it?
And how did you convince
them to take their word
to download a game that
takes a lot of effort
from you to start playing?
KRISTIAN SEGERSTRALE: Yeah,
that's a great question,
so how did we start?
We just started super
humbly because we
knew that, one, the product
was pretty janky when we first
released it.
We literally put
it live, I think,
it was in Singapore and in
the Philippines initially.
And we literally
put a letter up.
The first experience
you would have
when you loaded up
the game was a letter
from our chief creative officer
saying, hey, we're just getting
started.
We know this is not perfect.
Please bear with us.
We're a team of folks are super
passionate about this style
of gaming.
Please join us on
the forums to come
and chat about what you
think about this game.
And that was literally
the first thing
that you would see
when you started.
And literally the first
downloads that we got,
we were in the office.
We had an alert in the office
going when somebody is online,
because this is clearly
a multiplayer game.
So many people need to
play at the same time.
We would all jump into the game
so that that one guy would have
five other people to play with.
But it's true.
You have to approach it with
that level of dedication.
You have to earn every player.
Especially in our
case, we had so much
work to do on designs and just
learning about what it means
to play this type of game.
And we still have
a long way to go.
But if you approach
it with, you know
what, we're going to
do, first and foremost,
be there for the player and be
very transparent about the fact
that we know that a lot
of things suck still
and we're trying to
work on it with us,
but please come and work with
us, there's a lot of people
who, ultimately, if you
take the right tone,
want to help you succeed.
And that's an amazing
thing that really
teaches you so much about
your game and your company.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
I'm fascinated about this
topic of community building
in the sense that
I feel like myself
and a lot of other
indie developers
understand that it's
important, but fall
into the trap of
saying that we're too
busy building the game, right?
And the sort of solution for
this in other areas of life
is, for instance, with exercise.
If you don't have time for
exercise, build a habit.
Do 10 squats and 10
push-ups in the morning,
and that'll build up over time.
And eventually you'll feel
more interested in this habit,
so on and so forth.
So what's the 10 squats
and 10 push-ups version
of community building?
What do you do from
day one as a habit
that's small but potentially
painful but will build up?
ANDREW STALBOW: Set
up a Facebook channel,
Instagram channel, Twitter
channel, YouTube channel.
Promote it in the app and
publish content on there
about what you're
building every day.
Yeah, one piece
of content today.
Doesn't need to be a lot.
And I think the minute you
start doing that, you'll just
start getting into the groove.
And then you also
start realizing
your app's a great way to
promote each of those channels
too.
And suddenly it becomes
a bit of a circular thing
where people going
into one, coming back
into your experience.
And I think it's a great
way to get started.
AUDIENCE: Can I ask
a follow up quickly?
ANDRES BOU: And find some
time to talk with them also.
AUDIENCE: Can I quickly
ask a follow up?
So as I understand it, there's
sort of these two areas
in which you focus on
with community building.
There's acquisition
and there's retention.
And the sort of posts
seems like a great way
to build an emotional
investment with the following
that you already have.
So what's the 10
squats and 10 push-ups
of acquisition, if I can't
afford the Facebook ads?
I'm not going to
wake up every morning
and pay for some
Facebook ads, right?
But what would I do?
KRISTIAN SEGERSTRALE: You're
the kind of this, right?
ANDREW STALBOW: I'd
say go find people
that love your
experience and are
willing to shout about it for
free to very little money.
And go challenge yourself.
You know at the
end of the day, I
think there's some massive
platforms out there,
whether it's Twitch or
YouTube or whatever it may be,
where there's huge
audiences that
are always looking to learn
about new kind of gaming
experiences.
And I'd say go hustle
your way to figure out,
how do you get people to
start talking and sharing it
in your videos?
And get started with no budget
and challenge yourself on that.
Because that's
very, very doable.
KRISTIAN SEGERSTRALE: Yeah,
the one thing I would say
is that there's an awful lot of
incredibly passionate content
creators out there.
And just by being kind,
actually responding to them,
respecting their work, you
will get an awful long way,
if you can work out ways
of helping promote them.
Because their business problem
is, how do I get players--
or users rather,
viewers of my content?
Your business problem might
be how do I get new ones,
but theirs is just
like, how can I even
connect to a community
in the first place?
So by respecting that and
treating them as equals
and trying to figure out how
do we do this together as
opposed to figuring out
how do I throw money
at this sort of anonymous
group of influencers
who will bring me
millions of players,
that would be maybe my--
ANDREW STALBOW: One
other interesting way
to potentially approach it
as well is, go figure out
if there is a partnership with
another company that is looking
to kind of raise awareness
of what they're doing
in your product and
you can do some kind
of reciprocal arrangement.
When we started, we've done
that with a couple of other app
companies where we've both kind
of cross-promoted each other.
And that worked
out really nicely.
Another thing we
did was-- you know,
"Best Fiends" is all
about a whole load
of different
creatures in the game.
And one of them is
a mosquito called
Edward who gave up
his blood sucking ways
and he drinks coconut water
from a scuba tank on his back.
And we designed this character
and we did a partnership
with Malaria No More.
And straight away we
do a pop up in the game
and we cross-promote to a
co-branded Malaria No More
"Best Fiends" page.
And it's great for us because,
again it shows our audience
that we care and think
a bit differently
about our experience.
But they've also got a really
big community of people
as well that they were
excited to say, hey, here's
something we're doing.
And I think that was a
really nice kind of way
as well to start.
So just think a bit differently
about those kind of ideas.
AUDIENCE: Awesome.
Thanks so much.
DAVE GEFFON: So it's time
for one last question.
And we'll take it over here.
AUDIENCE: My
question for you all
is, how do you manage
a community that
looks to see your game grow
in a certain direction that
may be either
different or opposite
of where you're actually
looking to take the game?
ANDREW STALBOW: I would
say get used to it,
because your community
is always going
to have different
ideas about things
that you should or shouldn't do.
And ultimately your kind of
ability to work well with them
is to have somebody that can--
whether it's a
social media manager,
to be able to kind of
correspond with people
who always expect you to be
doing something different.
KRISTIAN SEGERSTRALE:
Yeah, I'd add to that
that listening to
your full player base
doesn't just mean listening
to the really loud ones.
So trying to figure
out, and also
being really transparent
about your own planning
and how you think about things
and why you think about things.
At the end of the
day, the community
is really great at
reacting to what they hear
or reacting to what they see.
The more they hear
or see from you,
the more refined their
ultimate reaction will be.
And if you really truly
try to please everyone,
you're not going to
please anyone in the end.
We're huge believers of
taking a stance as a game.
We know what we stand for.
Literally "Vainglory"
is all about
if you got Quentin Tarantino
to direct a manga movie,
you would get "Vainglory."
That is what we are.
We have snow
leopards with rocket
powered jet axes, right,
as opposed to just
your random Viking
brute, for example.
And we stand for that
style of gameplay.
We stand for a certain
amount of irreverence.
We stand for being
unapologetically core.
If somebody comes
in and says, hey, I
wish this game was much simpler
to play, that is, yes, we
hear you.
We want to understand how
to make it easier to learn.
We want to make sure
that we understand
how to create more meaningful
shorter sessions in the game,
all of those things.
But we will not make it simple.
That is not what we
are trying to do.
So I think its trying
to listen to the player
base with the thing in
mind that you want to make.
Because if you don't
stand for anything--
if you don't stand for anything
as a company and as a product,
I think you will have a very
hard time building a truly
passionate following over time.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ANDRES BOU: Just to add, I
think that happens every day.
I mean not only on gaming
with the communities,
also in real life with your
partner, with your employees,
with your peers.
I mean at the end,
we agree to disagree.
And there will be some
topics and some features that
will be suggested
by the community
and just, you have
to explain to them
why you took another direction.
And that's all you have to do.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
DAVE GEFFON: Excellent.
So thanks everyone for
attending the panel.
Coming up next, Sarah
Thomson is going
to lead a panel on
true indie stories.
So you'll want to stick
around and check that out.
But first let's give it up for
Kristian, Andrew, and Andres.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]